die lufthansa wird immer mehr zum boden
hansa und zur streik hansa vor allen
dingen und das mitten in den
sommerurlaub wochen sie werden dass
möglicherweise auch schon gespürt haben
die pilotengewerkschaft cockpit die hat
jetzt am wochenende per urabstimmung
beschlossen ja auch wir werden streiken
darüber müssen wir sprechen mit matthias
beyer dem presse vorstand der
vereinigung cockpit also der der dort
bei den piloten auskunft gibt aktuell
große herzlich
schön und wissen sie wen sie damit
treffen mit ihren angekündigten streiks
wir haben gar keinen streik angekündigt
wir haben eine urabstimmung durchgeführt
und diese urabstimmung ist keine
kampfmaßnahme eine urabstimmung dient
der interne willensbildung im verband
und hier hat sich das ergeben dass die
piloten der meinung der
konzerntarifkommission folgen dass die
verhandlung hier mit dem entsprechenden
forderungen weitergeführt werden soll
beziehungsweise die gespräche allerdings
sind die verhandlungen gegenwärtig ja
gescheitert beide parteien aber gesagt
sie sagen gesprächsbereit und eine
urabstimmung ist nicht das ende aller
möglichkeiten nein ganz im gegenteil wir
werden mit gesprächen weitermachen aber
jetzt noch mal klartext also für alle
urlauber für alle die flüge gebucht
haben müssen sie sich jetzt auf streiks
von ihnen einstellen oder gibt es ein
warnung von ihnen
weder das eine noch das andere kann ich
ihnen absolut sagen weil im moment hängt
jetzt davon ab wie diese gespräche
verlaufen und ich bin aber sehr
optimistisch dass das klappen wird es
ist ja auch nicht sind uns hier keiner
gewerkschaft zu streiken sondern es ist
hin und weg angemessene tarifverträge
auszuhandeln und in dem szenario
befinden wir uns jetzt
gegenwärtig gibt es keinen antrag auf
arbeitskampfmaßnahmen wie gesagt die
beiden parteien haben erklärt sie
möchten weiter miteinander reden und ich
glaube auch dass ein ergebnis erzielt
werden er drücke natürlich alle die
daumen dennoch sie sehen die langen
schlangen eben gerade an den deutschen
flughäfen es ist für uns jetzt mitten
zur urlaubszeit erfasst ja schon ein
bild des alltags ein absolutes frust
bild geworden was denken sie denn wenn
sie die urlauber da stehen wir kommen
alle aus zwei jahren pandemie wir haben
alle ein dickes brett im herbst und
winter vor uns wohl wenn ich wissen was
uns droht und jetzt hoffen alle da sind
wir uns hier drei einig dass es nicht
soweit kommt aber jetzt wenn man es so
zuspitzen lassen dass der streik
zumindest im raum steht das ist ein
guter zeitpunkt
ja hier treffen ja sehr viele sachen
auch wenn dann dazu ein muss man
verstehen dass die tarifverträge seit
dem ersten juli offen sind und man muss
auch verstehen dass die tarife parteien
seit juni miteinander über diese
vergütungsstrukturen hier reden sie sind
nicht zueinander gekommen ich habe
natürlich sehr grosses verständnis für
die befürchtung der passagiere niemand
ist gerne opfer einer
arbeitskampfmaßnahme und aber auch
niemand nimmt gerne an eine
arbeitskampfmaßnahme teil das heißt also
hier muss man einfach sagen gut lassen
die beiden parteien miteinander reden
dafür sie möchten gerne versuchen
aufeinander zu zu kommen und wenn das
alles so klar dann haben wir nichts zu
befürchten aber eine garantie kann ihnen
leider niemand gehen einmal noch karten
auf den tisch was verdient denn im
moment in pilot eigentlich vor allen
dingen auch gemessen an denen die da an
der schlange erstehen an den flughäfen
deutlich mehr oder
ja das kann ich gar nicht genau
einschätzen wo die bei wem die da stehen
in einer schlange ist gibt der ganze
reihe von fluggesellschaften
das ist eine große bandbreite also ich
nehme die plakative zahl die ja gerne
mal posiert der das erreichen sie nur
wenn sie wirklich sehr sehr lange bei
einer firma bleiben und dort auch bald
aufgestiegen sind möglicherweise sogar
trainings kapitän jack kapitän geworden
sind ist aber ein sehr langer prozess
und die meisten wie stolz ich mit
deutlich weniger und
jetzt 250.000 brutto im jahr das ist die
zeit die sie jetzt ansprechen wenn man
lange dabei ist lange schon fliegt dann
kann es zu diesem gehalt gehen hamburg
das kann dazu kommen ja das ist richtig
sie fangen aber mit deutlich weniger
anlagen
das ist überall so ganz genau dann
entwickelt sich das
es gibt manchmal deckel in den
tarifverträgen dann kommen sie nicht
weiter dann stoßen selber bleiben auch
für sehr lange zeit in diesem decke
hängen also da lässt sich das nicht an
ist denn der punkt da müssen wir schon
auf meine zahl sagen wo es sind die zahl
für die sie jetzt kämpfen wo sie sagen
das ist nicht gerecht gegenüber piloten
und dafür nehmen wir unter allen
eventualitäten wenn die gespräche
steigern auch in kauf dass die menschen
die wir in den bildern sehen dann noch
länger warten dass sie noch mehr frust
habe es ist vielleicht gar nicht in
urlaub schaffen und danach ellenlange e
mails schreiben weil sie ihr geld nicht
wieder bekommen wo ist die zahl wofür
sie sagen unsere schmerzgrenze ist
erreicht da reden wir nicht über 250.000
euro brutto
ja wir verhandeln ja keine absoluten
gehälter sondern wir verhandeln jetzt
eine steigerungsrate bzw das war das was
die konzerntarifkommission
vorgeschlagen hat und die rechtfertigt
sich dadurch dass wir natürlich eine
lange zeit haben in dem es überhaupt
keine oder nur geringe steigerungen
gegeben hat und wie in jeder
gehaltsverhandlung auch das kennen sie
und ich und jeder andere auch hier der
in einem angestelltenverhältnis sich
befindet erweisen muss um sein gehalt
natürlich verhandelt gewerkschaften
verhandeln sich nicht nach unten soll
wo es nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu
arbeiten gab für die blüten und piloten
in der pandemie konnte er nicht soviel
abgehoben werden wir vorher
sie ziehen jetzt haben auch die
vergangenen zwei jahre wenn sie jetzt
ganz speziell bei der lufthansa bleiben
dort hat die lufthansa im dezember
angefangen zurückzuzahlen und hat dann
auch im juli ganz überraschend gewinne
gemacht das ist aber jetzt nicht
entscheidend entscheidend ist dass die
arbeit die sind jetzt machen im nächsten
jahr die gleiche ist aber im
wahrscheinlich acht prozent weniger wert
ist und ich glaube da ist es ganz
natürlich dass wir erhält er nach oben
verhandeln wollen das macht ja versucht
hier praktisch jeder das ein bisschen
besser gestellt ist sagt matthias beyer
von der pilotenvereinigung cockpit der
einen streik hier leider bei bild live
nicht ausschließen möchte das hätten wir
uns so sehr gewünscht die anti streiken
hier bei bild.de wird diese urlaub danke
aber dennoch danke
als die währung schon klappen
[Musik]